hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have looking
you say about the action-packed
family-friendly Superman movies I love
them well most of them well some of them
two of them but either way the part of
the All American icon that is Superman
now of course good as these movies get
and as bad as these movies get they all
have their fill of stupid stupid moments
now I know they're supposed to be
lighter and more friendly but what's the
time that just come off as logically
idiotic that's why I have compiled a
list of the top 11 dumbest moments in
the Superman films why top 11 because I
like to go one step beyond so sit back
and enjoy the top 11 stupid as Superman
moe
number eleven the casting of Superman
Returns now I don't mean cast members
like Kevin Spacey and Frank Langella
they did okay what a mainly referring to
his Brandon brought that Superman and
Kate Bosworth as Lois Lane
I mean they weren't god-awful or
anything but they look 16 it's like if
Superman met Dawson's Creek oh wait they
already did that but you get my point
there's simply too young to be in these
bowls when I saw the first Superman
movie I didn't see actors I saw friggin
Superman and Lois Lane when I saw this
new movie I saw kids dressing up for
Halloween what the real actors go that's
cheesy I know on top of it
they were pretty bland I mean both of
them are supposed to be strong-willed
clever and spunky characters but here it
was like watching first graders holding
hands at the school play you didn't
really buy it it's a little Bailey and
it's the reasoning behind this casting
was despite this age Brandon Roth did
look an awful lot like Christopher Reeve
well that's the reasoning why did you
hire this kid then I don't know like I
said these two are horrible pictures
miscast
and when your protagonists look like
people you'd ask to the prom rather than
all-american heroes
something is definitely wrong personally
I think that's a little crap
number 10 the dumbass kid at Niagara
Falls from Superman - yeah you remember
this little moron
I mean I know you gotta put people in
perilous situations but how dumb is this
kid and where the hell is his mother
just don't fall off into the waterfall
okay honey I love five of your brothers
that way I know kids do stupid things
but this is pretty hard to swallow I
mean that the idiot have a death wish
my kid says he's probably friends with
that girl who plays hopscotch off a
cliff on that corn album of course
though
Superman comes in to rescue the boy and
save take that Darwin natural selection
doesn't win today there you go
no I'm sorry only one ride to a customer
and if you try to commit suicide again
I'll kill ya
number nine the romantic flying scene
recap from Superman for now we all
remember the flying scene from the first
Superman it was charming romantic and
all that other goofy stuff but when you
try to recreate it scene by scene that's
just embarrassing okay so it starts out
with Superman wanting to talk to Lois
about something important
rather than just flying to her apartment
like before she decides he wants to fuck
around with her a bit
no I thought the threat of imminent
death would be good for a laugh
seriously though I am a human God so
they decided to go flying around for
some reason as Louis has no questions
about her co-worker of 20 years being
the man of friggin Steel
she just had accepted it like she found
an extra 20 in her pocket now this scene
in all honesty wouldn't be quite so bad
if they didn't rip off every single
moment from the first one she is he
gonna fly through the city side by side
with her like the first one you bet
is he gonna support her with just his
fingertips which the loss of weight and
mass totally says it's impossible he you
know it he's he going to let her fall
just so he can swoop down and save her
well it wouldn't be a complete ripoff if
he didn't what it outside of just using
the direct clips there's absolutely no
difference between this scene and the
one from the first day what was the
point of it who knows maybe it was just
to take the number 9 spot on this Mirada
countdown
number eight the woman and the baby
carriage from Superman - I'm sensing a
pattern here that all mothers and
Superman movies are complete morons
Lois included in the latest film - how
much more obvious can you frickin get
but this one takes the cake as a large
tower is about to fall on a woman and
her baby so what does she do absolutely
nothing
no where's the nothing she covers the
child with her body yeah that'll save ya
brainless bet Bob they're called legs
you move a back and forth to create
already motion look at this at the rate
the tower is falling the way she's
standing there crying she's gonna run to
Florida and back by now
thank you for not making me more than
heels I almost killed my only son I
don't know why mothers are so stupid in
these movies but quite frankly this is
why I think sometimes you need a license
to be a parent like pets oxidation
number second the special effects of
Superman for to the credit of the first
two films you could never see those
wires that were holding him up Superman
for not so much look at all these wire
shots they don't even try to cover them
or how about the effects in the scene I
just showed you a moment ago yeah Lois
is fine pretty fast there isn't she
she's falling to the ground like a
feather and now how about this you can
actually see the black curtains that are
supposed to be outer space that's like
an Edwin movie how about this scene when
he's carrying the Statue of Liberty Wow
instant movie magic and how about this
one stupid blue screenshot that they
keep using over and over and over again
you think it's time went by the effects
would get better for these movies but
Superman's case it isn't the leg we
can't see through right on those thick
bulging wires that constantly keep
getting in the way this looks like a job
for Photoshop
number six
those stupid stupid glasses from which
movie all of them how come nobody can
ever see past them is it really that
great of disguise look there's even to
see where Louis takes off plus glasses
leaving and totally exposed I mean how
is everybody constantly fool this idea
is so flawed that just about everybody
in the world has made fun of it the tick
Mystery Men and many more it's a
suspension of disbelief that quite
frankly everybody disbelief but it could
be worse he could disguise himself as a
British nanny when secretly inside he's
just a Harry loud obnoxious comedian
wouldn't be nearly as blossom old one it
Clark Kent if you can't see past his
glasses and quite frankly you need
glasses and that's no shame
number five the birth of nuclear man
from Superman for now the first thing I
thought when I heard nuclear man was
that weird Captain Planet spin-off
captain pollution and to be fair I
listened really that far off nuclear man
was created from Superman's right all
the nuclear missiles of the world into
the Sun don't ask it's a long story as
Lex Luthor gives a snippet of Superman's
hair and uses its genetic material to
make a clone don't ask it's an even
longer story when the missiles are
tossed with the hair inside it gives
birth to nuclear man all right I'm
actually willing to buy some of this
nonsensical bullshit up to a certain
point and that point is who is born with
skin type spandex and a cape what
chapter of DNA genetic structure says
that's possible
I mean did he put a strand of Superman's
costume in there as well how does that
work well in any case nuclear man's
birthday suit is quite literally a suit
leaving us with all sorts of questions
of implausibility so since you're born
with an already fitted Gay Pride Parade
costume on what are you gonna do first I
have fun just like that I'm sure you'll
find it
another for the opening of Superman 3
talk about a movie that was already
doomed from the start
first of all look at these credits all
the Superman films began with the
credits flying in space with that
kick-ass jetLink music but this one it
looks like they were headed in at the
last minute it's like this stupid Star
Wars text option that comes with most
movie editing software and after that
it's pretty much just a half-assed
immoral and hearty as a guy trips
looking at a woman Olivia rollerblades
crashes into a hot dog cart
the hot dog cart knocked over some foam
boos a toy penguin is set on fire which
scares a little doggie that max a woman
over carrying groceries you get it's
about some noxious Li overblown as a
community can get looking absolutely
nothing like a Superman in fact the
title just passes by you wouldn't even
notice it but how can you what a man
confuses his walking dog for a road
painter yeah cuz all blind people are
friggin idiots right a car speeds out of
control hits a fire hydrant starts
filling up with water
you figure that one out as Superman
comes in to rescue the guy from drowning
in his own vehicle on dry bite this is
like the Dominos of human misery
seriously all that's missing to top off
this push a comedic slosh is a fucking
my this honestly does not seem Leah I
don't think there's enough wah-wah music
to get us through this opening
she once I get a comedic moment after
another the only thing missing
thank you thank you number three the -
brain blink kiss from Superman - this
happens after Lois finds out Superman's
secret identity they go all the way
through the movie and I mean all the way
until they get to the very end as
Superman feels Lois's life would be a
lot easier she never knew who he really
was
so he gives her a kiss that somehow
deletes all memory about him being
Superman what's happening in the world
does that work is there a mind-altering
breath mini Switzerland does his tongue
just work his way into her brain and
take out the parts he doesn't like for
that matter why doesn't he use this
power more often I mean it'd be weird he
could technically use that kiss to give
all the super villains at Mesa he fly up
to Lex Luthor and he'd be like Superman
allow me to explain my evil plot
who the hell am i I don't a be gross but
imagine how many lies you could say this
was obviously used to get people back to
the status quo Louis doesn't know who
Superman is so it keeps the romantic
mystery alive but really the only
mystery left in all of this is how the
hell did that kiss work not one of your
great thinkers
number two Richard Pryor is Superman
free now we all seen Richard Pryor on
stand-up and even in other movies so we
know this guy was not only funny he was
a comic legend but I think somebody
forgot to tell him that when he did
Superman 3 because good god this is one
of the unfunniest performances ever and
it wouldn't be so bad if he didn't had
too much screen time but to be honest I
think he actually has more time on
screen than Superman does just watch
some of his hilarious antics everything
right what his x-ray vision before he
did that dried up everything just like
that I'm talking about drying it up like
the machines that they have in the man's
rooms you know what I'm talking about
the hot air comes out you put your hands
in and you dry them off sometimes they
don't want it right a little
it's the Ross it was big Superman's bad
no you're bad I mean you were really bad
I seriously don't know who's to blame
the director the actor the writer I
don't know but nothing about him works
it's like one of those gamma rays came
out and sucked out all the money from
him I mean what happened don't call me a
bum I'm not a bum from comedic God to
comedic Claude this is one performance
from a comedy legend that I'm sure he
wants to forget thank the Lord
this mother man
and the number one dumbest Superman
moment is spinning the earth backwards
from Superman 1 it's ironic that the
first and best of the movie should have
the biggest flaw but in this nonsensical
moronic conclusion to an otherwise
flawless movie it's pretty hard to
overlook it all starts as Lois Lane
actually dies in an earthquake because
Superman could only stop one missile but
not the other so we have a very sad and
very dramatic moment which is suddenly
botched by probably the biggest cop-out
in Superman history Superman flies
around the world several times forcing
the rotation of the earth to go
backwards thus sending everything back
in time that way you can stop the other
missile allowing Lois to live where the
hell do I begin first if you stop the
earth and spin it back in time you
wouldn't time-travel people would just
fall off the friggin thing and everyone
will fly on the face of the earth
second if Superman can fly so fast that
he could spin the earth backwards why
the hell couldn't you just get both
missiles then look one will be there and
what will be there second even you with
your great speed couldn't stop both of
them no he's just fast enough to fly
around the earth and change the rotation
third if he went back to save Lois that
must mean there's another Superman
somewhere stopping the one of a missile
from before so really shouldn't be -
Superman's flying around I mean where's
the other one
and if he didn't get so angry because
Lois didn't die does that mean he
wouldn't have no reason to spend the
earth back to begin with for why hasn't
he done this before I mean wasn't there
a day when he came in late to work and
was like ooh
9:05 they'll dock my pay if I'm late
again
8:59 right on schedule
that's for problems with my number one
pick as people still today can't figure
out the technicals of this scene no
logic no reason no way that this moment
makes any sense whatsoever and those are
the top 11 stupidest Superman moments
but I have to admit for all the bad
times the Superman movies really do
manage to put me in a good mood I seen
Christopher Reeve right before he had
the tragic accident and died or Margaret
killed her right before she went
mentally insane are the shots of New
York with the World Trade Center in the
background I'm the Nostalgia Critic I'm
gonna go kill myself